President Trump is firing back after
federal court blocked the new version of
his controversial travel ban a federal
judge in Hawaii yesterday issued a
nationwide temporary restraining order
the ruling came just hours before the
revised executive order was to take
effect the ban would stop visas from
being issued to travelers from six
muslim-majority countries for 90 days
while the administration reviewed
vetting procedures Jan Crawford is in
Washington with the newest setback for
the president and his harsh words for
the judge Jan good morning good morning
so the new ruling came just over a month
after courts blocked the
administration's original order the
federal judge who blocked the latest
attempt said it was likely
unconstitutional religious
discrimination and last night President
Trump made clear he isn't backing down
this is the opinion of many an
unprecedented judicial overreach at a
campaign rally in Nashville the
president pulled no punches in attacking
the judge's decision this ruling makes
us look weak you don't think this was
done by a judge for political reasons do
you know President Trump even suggested
the White House reexamined its original
travel ban I think we ought to go back
to the first one and go all the way
which is what I want to do in the first
place but that first executive order
sparked protests at airports across the
nation opponents called it a Muslim ban
and the 9th Circuit Court of Appeals
blocked it the Trump administration then
revised the order removing Iraq from the
list of restricted countries exempting
visa holders and eliminating language
prioritizing Christian immigrants the
Muslim ban is something that in some
form has morphed into a extreme vetting
Hawaii federal judge Derek Watson who
was appointed by President Obama blocked
the revised ban citing past commentary
for mr. Trump and his inner circle like
White House senior adviser Stephen
Miller's assessment last month of the
new revision fundamentally you're still
gonna have the same basic policy outcome
for the country and Rudy Giuliani's
January comments on Fox News when he
first announced that he said Muslim ban
he called me up he said put a commission
together show me the right way to do it
legally in his ruling Watson wrote these
plainly worded statements betray the
executive orders stated secular purpose
now the judge completely discounted the
reasons the White House gave for this
temporary ban that those six countries
are in the grip of terrorist activity
that is highly unusual I mean typically
courts give president great deference on
matters of national security so this
could suggest that because of his past
comments courts are going to hold
President Trump to a different standard
gaile Jan thank you very much